i'm noticing a huge difference i'm
noticing a lot more lift and uber
drivers are out on the roads the wait
time has been severely
decreased we finally got numbers from
the government this morning that show
the end of pandemic unemployment
assistance the end of the extended
benefits we finally got to see what that
pipe you know pick through the python
looks like with most of americans back
at work and lo and behold we're seeing
lower lower spending among people who
have lost their unemployment benefits
what a shock
but my point is it's time for people to
go back to work and i think some people
are going to go back to work but there's
a conundrum in this morning's data
we've had three weeks three consecutive
weeks of rising initial u.s jobless
claims what's going on three weeks three
weeks in a row when's the last time you
saw that march excuse me april 2020.
last time we saw that was april 2020
which is coveted first month
gigantic but that was yeah
shut down stay home all that stuff now
tell me when you saw that pre-april 2020
oh well i mean they bumped around a lot
but three weeks but they were they were
they were at the lowest level in 50
years prior to the pandemic and then
they spiked up but again this is the
where
why are people getting fired in this
environment and i think there's a lack
of appreciation for
audio there's just there's a lack of
appreciation for how
american companies have said basta i'm
automating i'm replacing you with fl
there's there's a thing called flippy at
a white rock south of chicago and for 23
hours a day seven days a week down one
hour per day for downtime for cleaning
it makes french fries flippy's got a
friend behind him that makes burgers and
automation in this country is really
accelerating because companies are are
being told you have to pay higher wages
and they're like okay so what do we tell
our shareholders yeah i mean we're how
do we make a profit if we're paying
20 an hour for you to flip a burger it
just doesn't work the profits don't work
i've heard from around here that you've
got small restaurants that have
completely gone out of business because
they can't make the math work but in the
interim we've had companies really
accelerate this move to automate
so there's a lot of redundancies you're
not going to have as many jobs as you
had before and part of it is because
americans chose to not work when they
could have chose to not work when they
could have so is this where
the capitalist the innovator says no
problem you don't want to work i'm
always going to come up with a solution
my solution is i don't have a job for
you anymore go figure it out for
yourself and change your career because
the other day i was talking to kai i
don't know if you were on that one zoom
with the different
uh entrepreneurs one of the entrepreneur
man fields they want a pizza shop they
own several pizza shops they do very
well for themselves and they showed me
an idea about this one guy that is
building kitchens okay he creates all
the uh uh locations for you
all the equipment's in there like fifty
thousand dollars worth of equipment you
don't have to buy they simply rent it
out you at five thousand dollars a month
is what they do you got the kitchen
everything and it's a model with the
uber uh eats that comes and picks it up
or you know some of those models that
they're coming through and they said
there's a new machine that came out
doesn't need anybody it just makes
pizzas for itself i said what are you
talking about i said let me show it to
you they showed to me this machine no
joke it's three things that it shows
first the dough then it's the cheese and
then you program what to put in there
and it drops the pepper it drops the
mushroom it drops to whatever you want
and at the end the pizza comes out
without needing a person to actually do
that work so we innovate in the country
the reality of it is the entrepreneur
will always figure out a solution for
the challenge they're facing they're not
going to sit on their laurels and say
you don't want to come back to work oh
my gosh please come back please come
back no problem you don't want to we'll
find a replacement for you you know
everybody talks about working from home
and what my privileges and i i want to
have a flexible lifestyle well
working from home peaked out at about 40
something percent as of the most recent
non-farm payroll report it's down to
13.5 one 3.5 percent americans are
working from home
so the media hypes it up a lot what's
that percentage again 13.5
currently right i'm currently
it was it was north of forty percent
holy moly but that's the thing two
thirds almost yes but that's the thing
and the media makes it sound like you
know these millennials are gonna be able
to make their own lifestyle choices and
they're gonna be dictating all of the
all of all of what their work
requirements are to their employer the
employers have been you know basically
castrated
and
it's simply not the case but there are a
lot of jobs that and i'm not i'm
you're talking about a a machine that
makes pizzas
and i just heard that some mellow
mushroom in del rey went out of business
so that would have been a solution for
them
12 months ago so so then this more
validates elon musk's ubi is eventually
going to be eminent there's nothing we
can do about it it's coming do you agree
with him as well
well i i hope he's wrong and i think
that
um and i think we would agree on this i
think mitch mcconnell is making a last
stand
so that we can try and get out in front
of this and
it's it's not so much about the three
and a half trillion dollar bill no no
i'm talking about raising the debt limit
and the thing is jenny ellen was on the
hill she was on the hill testifying on
tuesday and she correctly said
that all we're doing by raising the debt
limit is paying a bill that we've
already incurred it would be like going
to a restaurant ordering a steak
this is the example she used eating the
steak and then refusing to pay the bill
so these are just seven some odd
trillion dollars of debt that we've
already incurred as a country and the
debt limit has to be raised in order to
cover that tab
but the reason back in 2011 standard
poor's downgraded the sovereign debt
rating of the united states from aaa was
because
in in in the negotiations to raise the
debt ceiling
congress refused to address long-term
entitlement spending you hear about all
the time look social security is going
to run out of money by 2034 medicare
medicare medicaid all of this
entitlement spending has never been
addressed and what mcconnell is saying
is we're not just going to give you a
free pass because the minute we raise
that debt ceiling you're going to ram
through three and a half trillion
dollars of a social spending bill purely
on party lines he's looking at the
midterm elections and trying to stop
what you're talking about stop what elon
musk is is predicting will happen to
this country
tom you're well the two sides to it and
first of all great to see you again and
it's great great to be back here we we
have to come to florida to seattle you
realize we live in the same city that's
right or or the american lounge
laguardia by accident indeed true true
so
which what you have is two things that
happened over the nine months right
during the nine months we kept spending
money so this nine-month debate that's
been going on we've been spending and so
janet yellen is correct we've already
spent the money over nine months people
are retiring everything the entitlements
are going the spending has been
happening so that's our but i want to
step back to something go back about two
minutes here do you remember i think it
was two and a half years ago three years
ago de blasio did the thing it was a
double punch first he said uh fast food
in new york need to have a uh a living
wage and so it's like a minimum um
what was it 10 50 or 12 that he wanted
to remember that on that and at the same
time he said this is too much sugar and
held up held up a big year that you can
freely go by if you want so at that time
do you remember
what there is a mcdonald franchisee that
started working with southwest
previously on the kiosks so that people
could have quick and accurate orders
could immediately select their language
there was all these benefits not just
eliminating another teenage kid that was
making money it was language it was
selection it was accuracy it was speed
in the most important two hours of the
day 11 to 1 midday
so guess what
this
what we're seeing here with automation
everything happening under covet did not
happen now the entrepreneurs were given
a sign and a signal from people like de
blasio a couple years ago on minimum
wage and what they were going to enforce
on their business and you gave
entrepreneurs a two-year head start to
start finding solutions and now
covid comes out and guess what the
market's pretty big for those solutions
and they could sell them to a lot of
they've been accelerated and amplified
this whole move to automation so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]